so-called fake news can have real-world
consequences
well communicating 1/3 I will write so
this is an arms race I mean they're
gonna keep on getting better at this and
we need to invest in keeping on getting
better at this too many of my students
actually helps the American president
win the elections how much
responsibility does Facebook have for
the content on the platform so Facebook
knew that this was happening and you're
saying they were profiting I'm a
matchable Dean and this is a story about
fake news and the people profiting from
it in the three months leading up to the
2016 US election viral fake news stories
generated more total engagement on
Facebook and those from the top 19 major
news outlets combined some of these fake
stories came from an unlikely place the
Republic of North Macedonia a country of
about 2 million people just north of
Greece there's all these stories about
you know guys over in Macedonia who are
running these fake news sites we found a
lot of different accounts coming from
Macedonia hundreds of proton websites
popped up all over the country and
teenagers particularly in one former
factory town purportedly made millions
by duping American news consumers on
social media sites like Facebook
I came to Macedonia to find out what the
fake news industry here is like amid a
tech industry crackdown and reports that
trolls are already preparing to cash in
on the next US elections I was telling
about our informal title to Macedonia
the length of the fake sashka Tsvetkov
ska is an investigative journalist in
Skopje Macedonia is capital she says
it's not a coincidence that Macedonia
has become one of the world's fake news
hubs
it has a young tech-savvy population an
unemployment rate of over 20% and the
recently ousted government regularly
blasted fake news through state-run
media with somehow managed to create
quite good people that work in IT can be
anywhere in the world and you can get a
very high skilled
nice cool people she's investigating
who's funding the fake news factories in
the country it's really hard to trace
these I think it's a lot of people in
many governments many powerful centers
corporations - at the center of
Macedonia's fake news industry is a man
named Mirko sessile Kowski he calls
himself an internet marketing consultant
and Facebook strategist though he's been
referred to as a clickbait coach he says
he's taught over a thousand young people
here how to make content for an American
audience you refer to yourself as the
man who accidentally helped Donald Trump
win the US election many of my students
actually helps I think they helped the
American president win the elections
maybe with a small push of information
from our side
Mirko started making money on the
Internet in the early 2000s by writing
stories about yachts and muscle cars he
insists it was purely by accident that
his students stumbled upon the money pot
that his US partisan politics here's how
this works
create a simple website through a site
like WordPress choose a domain name that
sounds like a mainstream American news
organization copy and paste stories from
all right sites like Breitbart and
Infowars
then create or buy Facebook profiles
pages and likes when readers click
through from Facebook to the websites
they're hit with dozens of ads with each
click the ad revenue begins pouring in
through automated advertising engines
like Google Adsense the secret
ingredients for a viral hit explosive
title shocking image did your students
know much about the US or US politics
before they started writing these
stories no when when the money started
to come they hired some students here at
the university the most successful
students even hired US students from
America from America yes Mirko says his
students often hire freelance writers in
the United States through websites like
at work during the elections and the
year before the elections and several
months after
elections I had students with revenue of
north of 100,000 per month u.s. dollars
that's a lot of money especially in
Macedonia do you feel that there's a
moral or ethical concern to be making
money off of convincing millions of
Americans that something is real that
can then affect how they vote yeah it's
not moral it's not ethical definitely
but it's not illegal here in Macedonia
Facebook's crackdown on fake news has
been bad for business here in 2020 for
example yeah there's another huge
election yeah you think there will be
people doing the same thing there are
some different methods we teach now and
you can you need to invest a lot more
after meeting Mirko I traveled to a
small town that has become the epicenter
of the fake news industry here I'm here
in Valis Macedonia a former factory town
where young people if they're lucky to
have a job at all rarely earn over 300
euros a month but where fake news
factories are now making some of them
very rich I'm on my way to meet a young
man named Boris who's learned from
mirko's methods and works in a Content
Factory along with 20 others
we weren't invited inside instead he
agreed to meet me at an internet cafe
boris has asked that we conceal his
identity because he's afraid of legal
action from the US he didn't want to
share just how much money he's made
worried and might reveal his identity
generally you work at night right if you
want to reach more audience you'll work
the same time from the United States if
if you ask where you can you will start
the debate at the same moment and
everyone will start commenting it's more
interesting can you get more fans more
likes original what do you think about
these Americans who are reading all this
fake news the stuff you were publishing
if Americans like swine who we give wine
if Americans likes water we give water
what American wants to read I will write
and how did you know what Americans you
will test it what Boris told me next
caught me by surprise Facebook is a
social media network that allows these
stories to go so viral so Facebook knew
that this was happening three weeks
before the election if you write Donald
Trump you will see zero comma zero four
cents per like if you write Hillary
Clinton will be 20 cents 40 cents 50
cents that's the moment when faith
decides to go Donald Trump oil
Boris is saying that in the days before
the election the price for promoting
content that was Pro Trump on the pages
he was managing dropped significantly
so he went all-in to heavily promote
Trump what are your plans in the next
election maybe 2020 I would think about
it and then I'll also discuss my time in
Macedonia left me with a lot of
questions so I returned to the u.s. in
search of answers we came here to
Facebook's headquarters to find out what
went wrong in the 2016 elections and
what their plans are to protect the
integrity of future elections in the US
and abroad
Monica bickered is head of content
policy at Facebook well this is
definitely an area where we've made
mistakes and where we're investing a lot
in getting better so if you look back
to 2016 for instance our tools that
identify fake accounts weren't as good
then as they are now we've come across a
lot of accounts that are Macedonian and
Russian accounts that seem dubious to us
throughout the reporting process but
they're still active
well we won't always be perfect but I
can tell you it's absolutely a priority
to proactively find and remove those
types of accounts in the lead up to the
French and German elections in 2017
Facebook removed tens of thousands of
fake accounts but the company announced
recently that there may be as many as
eighty seven million fake accounts still
on the platform Facebook is hiring
thousands of people to review contact
developing artificial intelligence to
detect fake news and accounts and trying
to contextualize articles that have been
flagged as potential fakes so users can
decide for themselves what would you say
to American Facebook users who are
concerned about fake news and how it
might influence the midterm elections
Facebook certainly has a role to play in
removing inauthentic actors fake
accounts people who were intentionally
sharing disinformation to sow discord at
the same time there's also more that we
can be doing as a society to identify
when something is likely fake I asked
her about Boris's allegations that
Facebook was profiting off of content
like his and he claims that Facebook
knew whether it was an algorithms
decision or humans that the price was
all of a sudden dramatically cheaper to
promote Trump content well for
advertising prices I'd have to follow up
with you on exactly how we said this but
we didn't receive an explanation on the
record from the company despite repeated
attempts to obtain one former facebook
employee Antonio Garcia Martinez has his
own take on Boris's claims he was a
product manager who helped develop the
platform's advertising side and left the
company in 2013 what do you make of that
because it can be coincidence but that's
what may not be I mean if you employ a
certain inflammatory rhetoric that yes
people engage with your thing then your
net media cost will be lower that is how
Facebook
designed to work but it's kind of
problematic right didn't come up with
this good what are the same thing but
I'm yeah it is in this context I think
you're right that maybe it is
problematic it seems like everyone
benefited that was in that game that's
right that's right as did the Trump
campaign Antonio's critical of the
company's early attempts to minimize the
fake news problem you know personally I
think the the idea that you know fake
news on Facebook influence the election
in any way I think is a pretty crazy
idea to discard the possibility that
face we could actually swing the
election so so quickly is obviously
really disingenuous and and frankly not
true why so so literally until like 72
hours before the election there was a
huge political ad sales force which
Facebook has telling every politician
with the marketing budget exactly the
opposite that Facebook can deliver than
the election Antonio says that the
reason this matters comes down to a
simple but fundamental question how much
responsibility does Facebook have for
the content on the platform that really
is the big question so how does the
company fix this proper iliyan dollar
question I don't know I don't think
Facebook knows the answer to it either
in his recent Senate hearing mark
zuckerberg addressed the challenge of
staying ahead of fake news before it
impacts future elections so this is an
arms race I mean they're gonna keep on
getting better at this and we need to
invest in keeping on getting better at
this too what will happen in 2020 other
countries maybe will want to make big
money then you countries more countries
will start the same thing but others
have political ends in sight so be sure
to check out this video we did an
interview with an investigative
journalist in Russia who went undercover
in a troll farm